[Applaus]
seit gestern treffen sich die Grünen in
Karlsruhe zum gemeinsamen abheulen ja
ausgerechnet in Karlsruhe wo die bösen
Richter wohnen die ihn gerade erst 60
Milliarden geklaut haben für ihre
Projekte vier Tage Parteitag unter dem
offiziellen Motto machen was zählt
ehrlicher wäre scheiße was machen wir
denn jetzt nach den letzten Monaten ja
herbe grüne Verluste in Bayern und
Hessen und dann hat die Parteispitze
auch noch beef mit der eigenen Basis
quasi beef of
Sojabasis man könnte auch sagen es droht
ein ziemliches Tofu wabohu
entschuldigung ich höre jetzt auf ich hö
jetzt auf in einem basisbrandbrief heißt
es wir wirken wie eine Partei die alles
mitträgt egal wie sehr es eigenen
moralischen und politischen Grundsätzen
zu widerläuft gut immerhin einig ist man
sich beim Thema Schuldenbremse die muss
weggeboxt werden am besten mit völlig
sinnlosen boxmetaphern mit der schönen
Bremse wie sie ist haben wir uns frei
freiwillig die Hände auf den Rücken
gefesselt und ziehen in einen boxampf so
wollen wir den gewinnen die Anderen
wickeln sich Hufeisen in die Handschuhe
und wir haben doch nicht einmal die Arme
frei oder oder noch poetischer
ausgedrückt wir haben schlimmen
Durchfall keine Arme und das Papier ist
alle whatever Metern Robert der
Zeitgeist meint es nicht gut mit den
Grünen im Sommer 22 standen die in
Umfragen noch bei über 20% jetzt sind es
noch knapp 14 schlechtester Wert seit 5
Jahren ja deswegen ist dieser ist dieser
Parteitag auch so eine Art
Gruppentherapie Neues wirgefühl muss her
in einer Partei die sich nicht mal mehr
einen geberdendolmetscher leisten kann
und dieser Politik diese Politik des
Ellenbogens setzen wir entgegen eine
Politik des Herzes und der
Vernunft
ja danach kam noch was wir Grünen dieses
Jahr rund ums heizungsgesetz abgeliefert
haben das war ja wohl voll für ein Arsch
ja zum das war zum
mäuseelken bzw zum egal wenn das jetzt
der neue Trend ist übrigens der
eigentliche Showdown kommt ja erst
morgen Abend beim Thema Migration auf
dem Parteitag die Basis fordert
Rückbesinnung auf grüne Werte zuletzt
sei man von einer Partei für echte
Veränderung zu einer Werbeagentur für
schlechte Kompromisse geworden das finde
ich ein bisschen hart die klingen doch
nicht wie eine Werbeagentur bitte tun
die doch wir zeigen Ihnen heute hier
erstmals unser neues
grundlagendesign mit dem wir uns optisch
modernisieren und wir haben uns
weiterentwickelt als Partei und wir
haben uns entschieden hier eine dunkle
Farbe wir nennen sie Tanne zu wählen als
Hauptfarbe die eben auch diesen
verantwortungston auch noch mal zeichnet
diesen verantwortungsans
[Applaus]
Spruch die Tanne zeichnet
Verantwortung verkaufen die jetzt
Badezusatz oder was ja ja das kennen wir
natürlich aus der Werbung wenn eine
Marke total im Arsch ist kommt ein neues
Design ne das ändert zwar nichts am
Produkt aber lenkt vielleicht ab von all
den Kröten die man in der Ampel
schlucken musste denn das ist ja auf die
Dauer geradezu
ungesund erschreckende Zahlen jeder
dritte grüne leidet heute an chronischen
Nackenschmerzen nun haben Mediziner
herausgefunden Schmerzursache ist das
ständige abnicken von faulen
Kompromissen in
ampelkoalitionen und genau deshalb
müssen wir lüzerat wegbaggern ja die
Folge Verschleiß der Halswirbel ein
Physiotherapeut versucht hier einer
betroffenen inzwischen völlig verlernte
Kopfbewegungen beizubringen h es
Kopfschütteln ne einmal von links nach
rechts wieder links und und jetzt bitte
einmal dabei nein sagen
Ja
Nein Ursache der seltenen Krankheit
Morbus grün ist fehlendes Rückgrat und
in chronischen Fällen hilft leider nur
noch die antiabnik Halskrause holen Sie
sich jetzt Ihre kostenlose Beratung bei
der Barmer nackenschule endlich weniger
nicken
müssen
ja
hier schon gesehen jetzt im Grünen
Fanshop die Vorsitzenden als lustige
abnickdackel ja dabei heißt es doch nett
ist die kleine Schwester von hier
Kompost
ne und das ganze brav bei fußs sitzen
hat ihn ja nicht mal was gebracht im
Gegenteil in Hessen hat die CDU sie nach
10 Jahren geräuschlos mitregieren und
abnicken einfach vor die Tür gesetzt
hier Boris rin trennt sich aber auf die
sanfte t aber mein Dank gilt ganz
ausdrücklich den häsischen Grünen wir
haben eine Zusammenarbeit erlebt die von
größter Zuverlässigkeit
unverlässlichkeit geprägt ist wir haben
in diesen 10 Jahren enorm viel erreicht
ich persönlich habe den Grünen auch viel
zu verdanken ich will auch das Betonen
von einem freundschaftlichen Miteinander
wir haben gemeinsam sehr erfolgreiche
für Hessen gearbeitet darauf wollen wir
jetzt aufbauen das ist der Grund warum
wir uns für die SPD entschieden haben
okay den plotwist am Ende habe ich nicht
kommen sehen muss ich sagen ja
schwarzgrün ist plötzlich ein
Auslaufmodell und Grünen besching der
neue Volkssport und das ist ja auch ein
bisschen tragisch ich meine wir Bürger
wissen ja tief drin dass es Veränderung
braucht aber wenn sie dann kommen sind
wir voll wütend auf die Grünen die
natürlich auch selber viel gemacht haben
für ihr Elend na wie gesagt Stichwort
heizungsgesetz diese arschteure
kompromissgeburt die am Ende viel zu
wenig fürs Klima bringt apropos haben
sie mal gesehen wie der Habeck zuletzt
gealtert ist das ist ja erschreckend ist
ja Wahnsinn ja und es ist ja auch kein
Wunder ich meine seine Projekte gehen
gerade den Bach runter wie verarbeitet
man den ganzen Frust gut in seinem Fall
wahrscheinlich mit neuen Kinderbüchern
wie weißt du eigentlich wie scheiße dein
Job ist wenn du mit der fucking FDP
regierst oder ich zertrete vor lauter
Wut die kleine Raupe nimmer satt und
natürlich ich habe dem kleinen Maulwurf
auf den Kopf gemacht und weißt du was
ich würde wieder
tun die Grünen neulich noch Volkspartei
jetzt wieder klientelerein gefangen in
der lastenradbabbel was soll man den in
dieser Lage raten was ich weiß es nicht
fragen wir also den heute schon
Mitarbeiter der am ehesten aussieht wie
ein verlebter altgrüner Friedemann
weise Ratschläge in die Fresse mit
Friedemann
Weise wie sang schon der große cher K
mit der
[Musik]
Frosch ja es ist wirklich nicht leicht
mittlerweile hacken alle auf den grünen
rum die Angriffe von rechts kann man ja
noch als Auszeichnung verstehen aber
wenn jetzt schon die eigene Basis auf
die Barrikaden geht sollte man sich da
nicht langsam mal Gedanken machen ja was
ist die
Frage die Frage ist was mit euren
Grundsätzen ist ihr wurdet gewählt für
das was in eurem Programm stand und auf
euren Plakaten gucken wir doch mal wie
die so gealtert sind hier direkt der
Klassiker keine Waffen und Rüstungsgüter
in Kriegsgebiete und nein ich rede jetzt
nicht von der Ukraine sondern von
Unrechtsstaaten wie Saudi-Arabien dahin
genehmigt ihr mit der Ampel
Waffenexporte in Rekordhöhe es tut mir
herzlich leid schon okay was noch Züge
Schule Internet ein Land das einfach
funktioniert okay den lass ich euch das
ist wirklich lustig noch was
kommt wir bauen das neue Europa immerhin
das läuft doch die Zäune stehen fast
schon alle dank der asylreform der auch
ihr zugestimmt habt am Klimaziel führt
kein Weg vorbei umso erstaunlicher dass
ihr offensichtlich doch einen Weg
vorbeigefunden habt ich sag's mal
bildlich wenn das Klimaziel die
Zugspitze wä dann steht ihr gerade in
lüzerad und buddelt euch noch tiefer in
die Erde was noch wir rett Bienen retten
uns kein richtiger Satz aber ein
wichtiges Thema der atenschutz ist euch
grün so wichtig da drückt ihr sogar bei
Kinderarbeit ein Auge zu umso besser
dass wir jetzt einen grünen
Landwirtschaftsminister haben was macht
der eigentlich gerade ja ich bin heute
bei der Metzgerei stuhlberger und durfte
heute Wurst abdrehen Wurst abdrehen
wolltest du nicht der Agrarindustrie den
glyphosatan abdrehen doch wolltest du
aber bei der Verlängerung der EU
Zulassung um weitere 10 Jahre bist du
vor der FDP eingeknickt und deshalb hat
sich Deutschland bei der Abstimmung
enthalten warum eine Enthaltung ich sag
noch mal ausdrücklich eine Enthaltung
wird gewertet wie ein Nein ja dann stimm
doch mit Nein im Koalitionsvertrag steht
klipp und klar wir nehmen Glyphosat bis
Ende 2023 vom Markt wie soll das jetzt
noch klappen ein nationales Verbot an
der EU vorbei vergiss es das hat
Luxemburg schon probiert und es damit
vor Gericht gescheitert mein Ratschlag
macht endlich wieder die Politik für die
ihr gewählt wurdet das hat doch bei
rotgrün auch geklappt exumweltminister
Jürgen Trittin hat damals gegen
sämtliche Widerstände sein dosenfand
durchgesetzt und im Nachhinein muss man
sagen er hat damit mehr als jeder andere
grüne gegen Altersarmut getan das fand
könnte auch mal wieder erhöht werden was
ist los mit dir her grrise ich nicht
aber ihr die eigene Basis nennt euch
Werbeagentur für schlechte Kompromisse
eigentlich eine gute Idee macht die
Partei zu und eine Agentur auf ich hätte
auch schon den passenden Namen Scholz
and friends
tschüss RGE in die Presse mit
we die haben gesagt ich soll meinen
Lieblingswitz erzählen ja das mache ich
gerne also komm ein perd Chef besos und
der Papst in eine Bar sagt der Barkeeper
abonniere endlich den verkackten heute
sch Kanal also geht doch